[Music]
elizabeth joins us in norfolk virginia
elizabeth welcome to the show how can we
help
hello it's so exciting to talk to you
we're excited to talk to you what's
going on in your world
so i just need some advice my husband
and i are on baby set four and five
we're hoping to build a home
this coming fall so that's why we're not
on six we currently rent right now okay
um but i've had
some controversy
in my current employer with my current
employer
and it's been a difficult last four
months
a little bit of just burnout on my side
and moving towards just i don't want to
say toxic but it's it's just been an
uncomfortable working environment so
what's the code also
so um i'm currently an assistant manager
um i work in healthcare to them and it's
just
i'm sorry i'm just making an office
reference assistant to the regional
manager that's all
oh
so um yeah so i'm in healthcare i'm an
assistant manager and healthcare is a
very difficult climate right now and my
boss and i aren't necessarily seeing eye
to eye
we've had some conversations
and it's moved forward
and it's just become a question of my
work ethic
and whether i'm pulling enough hours
whether i'm meeting the job requirements
or not i've tried to receive it very
positively so that i can move forward
and be what my team needs me to be
in my work environment but then it's
also affecting just how much i'm at home
which is very difficult because i have
three young children and i'm trying to
balance being everywhere i need to be
right now yeah
let's back out thirty thousand foot feet
for a second
how are you you mentioned burnout you
mentioned you got three little ones you
mentioned be in a bunch of different
places how are you in this season
i'm
very burned out
you're cooked i've been in i've been
i've been a nurse for 15 years okay in
an emergency department so i'm cooked
that's right um you really are you're
cooked
if we're honest and i i've
got i've spent years working with folks
in your world
you're cooked before kovid and this is
like nothing else right afterwards right
the last two years have been
insanity for for nursing professionals
so
is the so let's go back into the
hospital now is the criticism you're
receiving fair and there's a point to
why i'm asking you this stuff
no
no
okay
sometimes not sometimes always when i'm
get chaotic when i get exhausted when i
am dealing with kid stuff and i don't
gotta run over here my wife needs me to
and then it just happens to be the day
that one of the folks that i work with
here says you know what you need to
really step it
they're often right and as frustrating
or as angry as it makes me when they
when they say something when james is
like hey delaney you got to be on time
man he's right you know what i mean
but you're saying your boss is not right
and in fact your your boss is
contributing to this feeling not calling
out things that are going to help things
correct
okay
so do you still want to be a nurse
some days
not
yeah
is that new or is that long
long-standing
that's long-standing okay okay
so back to your original question how
close are you to the end here
well
we're hoping to build in the fall
so
our income is a huge driver to this
question because we've made more than
we've ever made before our income is
about 175 a year 175 000 a year
so we're really
saving a lot because we have this end
goal of finally building the home that
we want which would require us
moving
and
new jobs
new schools everything but elizabeth you
build this house
and it requires you to die every day to
do it will it be worth it
i hope so
i'm telling you right now it will not be
okay one of the hardest things about
reaching goals is that we go with us
wherever you end up you will be there
and if you are fried and cooked and
exhausted then you're gonna be fried and
cooked and exhausted in a brand new
fancy house with new schools you're just
gonna be more stressed because you had
to move and change schools with three
little ones
yes i would much rather you see you
square your heart and your mind and your
professional life up
and make it more in line with the
reality that three kids is thrown into
your life whatever your husband and your
relationship looks like i'd much rather
you line those things up and then say
what do i want to do what do we want to
do
and then say how do we fit our dream
goals which is building a house buying a
boat whatever moving to paris whatever
that is can we do that in
in in reality
do you hear do you hear like just listen
back to what you've told us you're
basically sacrificing yourself
for this other dream over here
yeah
have you looked at other other jobs
do you know that this is the only place
that you can work that'll pay you this
much
no i i haven't
i think that's a good first step
because i think in your head you're
going well if i go to another job i'm
not going to make as much why are you
scared to
because this is i've done this for so
long i know what i'm doing yeah the
devil you know if i step out of my i
step out of my comfort zone
i have to learn something else
yeah but you're capable of that you're
amazing
you can absolutely learn something new
you can start somewhere fresh you're
going to move somewhere fresh anyways
right you just told us that
that's true so i would start looking and
if it's in the new area that you guys
want to live that's not a bad thing
either
and you can rent for there for a little
while maybe a six month lease until you
can build this dream home but there's
really nothing driving the urgency of
this home other than we want to right
but there's something driving the
urgency of the other side of this
equation which is you cannot keep going
like you're going
it's exhausting it is would you take a
10 000
pay cut per year
if it meant you weren't in a toxic
environment and it slowed down this home
process by a month or two would you do
it
yes i think we have our answer i think
you've got to do some research and not
be afraid of the unknown because you're
about to step into it anyways if you're
going to move to a new town with new
jobs and new house and all of that stuff
so you can do hard things elizabeth can
i tell you uh where i would start with
this elizabeth if i'm you because i know
it feels overwhelming
have you sat down with your husband and
told him i'm not okay
we talked about it okay
but i told him i could push through if i
needed to okay
i would love to see you and take him to
dinner
and
you all sit down and have a honest
conversation because i think you've
hinted at it hoping he would pick up on
it and pull the plug on this deal or
hint at it and say well i can you know
what i'm saying and i think it's time
that you are able to lay all the cards
on the table and say
we got three kids we've got this we've
got that we've got that you and i
our relationship has changed not for
better or worse it's just different now
we got three kids we're both working
full time things are bananas
and
i can't continue
at this trajectory whether that means
i'm getting out of nursing whether that
means
i want to stay at home with the kids
whether that means i got to just change
hospitals because i can't work with a
supervisor anymore i got to change
whatever that means
i think we need to sit down on the table
with your number one fan your chief
partner in life and say
i'm out i can't go anymore like this and
i don't know what this means yet and i
promise that i'm going to get to the
bottom of it
and then let's build something new
together man i feel for the healthcare
workers john that's i think everyone is
experiencing some level of what she's
experiencing unbelievable it's hard been
through toxic long hours
no end in sight
i feel for you elizabeth good luck on
your journey this is the ramsay show